(sexy, sensual jazz music)
- People always think
that its just sexual,
everything that's happening there,
but actually you're having a lot of fun.
- People are always assuming
that things that happened
over there are mostly
erotic, intimate moments.
- I mean a lot of the
guys, they just wanna talk.
- It's more about fun,
being wild on camera,
and just being yourself.
Those are actually the
most memorable stories.
- So I have many memorable stories.
- I already knew this guy.
I knew he was coming
there for only the fun
and entertaining reason.
He didn't want anything sexy.
Nothing to do with it.
- He was watching me for
a while in free chat.
He watched when my body
moves and things like that.
He asked me, like, "Could
you please teach me
"how to be like a sensual woman
"and how to attract men?"
Of course, we are not
laughing about anyone because
it's part of the fetish.
The memorable thing, it's,
he's willing, like how much he was trying.
- So at some point, he
was ironing his clothes
and taking me private.
He started playing with me Truth or Dare.
I kind of lost a dare and I had to put
a pile of clothes on me.
- I told him, like, "Just
the way you are looking.
"Keep your hand like this.
"Do like this with your hair.
"Play with your hair."
Of course he didn't have
hair, so it was funny.
He was bald.
I was actually teaching
him how to work his hips
to something like Shakira, I said.
That was very funny.
At some point, he started to laugh, too.
It was memorable because
he was so willing to
learn all the steps that I was giving.
- T-shirts, sweatshirts,
three pairs of yoga pants.
Afterwards, me, still being
with the pile of clothes on me,
I had to do some yoga moves.
- There was a member that
literally just wanted me to
act like I was speeding in his car.
- I had this member, he took me in private
without saying to me what he want to do.
- He literally just wanted
me to roleplay out that
I was speeding his car and
that I was cussing him out
because he was telling
me to stop speeding,
and it was just really different for me,
so that's why it was so memorable.
He just told me, "Act
like you're speeding.
"Push your foot down to the floor.
"Let me see you push the car to the metal
"and tell me to shut the (bleeping) up."
- And he started to give me
a video with Tom and Jerry
and to dress like Tom in
blue jeans and white socks.
- He had me telling him to shut up,
that I'm gonna go as fast as I wanna go,
and he just enjoyed me yelling at him
and telling him that he was a punk for not
letting me speed.
- To watch that video and
to act exactly like Tom.
How Tom acted in that video,
to act exactly like him.
He didn't give me his cam.
Probably he laughed and
it was just so funny,
I laughed so much.
I had fun.
- We have a lot of memorable
stories but overall,
all the experience it's
actually helping you be
more open minded.
After all, a person that's
coming on a site as a member,
he is trying to get something
new that's not happening
actually in real and probably
he would never try in real.
So they want something,
either if it's sexual or fun,
they just want something
new, because if everything
would be just the same every time,
it would be kind of boring.
So, having these kind of things,
given the fact that it's
also making you laugh
and it's raising your mood,
(chuckling)
it's also helping you be more open minded.
(soft, funky music)